in the pristine rainforests of Borneo
there's a hidden battle between groups
of poachers and wildlife photographers
they both share the same mission finding
the helmeted hornbill an iconic bird
pushed to the very brink of extinction
due to poaching
[Music]
this group of poachers have been
operating since 2009 killing around a
hundred helmeted hornbills to sell on
the black market
but the birds are getting more and more
difficult to find they have to
the endangered helmeted hornbill which
is becoming extremely rare in borneo
rainforest is the only hornbill species
in the world whose cask is composed of
ivory light material but not everyone is
out to kill the helmeted window it also
has many protectors we are now driving
into one of the poorest reserve in sabah
there are many animals and wildlife that
found in this forest
especially many varieties of species of
hornbill pied hornbill black horn bill
reform bill rhinoceros hornbill and the
ultimate helmeted marvel but this is one
of the oldest rainforests and it's one
of the largest forest reserve in sabah
and we hope to find what we're targeting
we helmet
I see young given locus in Japanese
another city needle monkey then about
this young their avatar to dinner and
more flora brunoise hello palma de rehén
de tomate erskine young Gatos wat often
but when W 2 square of gravity' focus it
to us
[Music]
what's special about the helmeted
hornbill is it's a large bird it has a
very long tail it has red neck it's
different from the other smaller
hornbills and they are rare and they are
much rarer than the other hornbill and
it's harder to find so if you find one
it's it's a great feeling you know so to
find one it's not easy
you've got to go out in the jungle and
track them and listen to them
after three days hiking in Betim carajo
National Park
poachers Anto and Umberto's couldn't
find any helmeted hornbill
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Bharani to Baja mechanic a tough winter
tari tari - oh yeah yeah McGavin da da
another situation to another own - maja
mechanic it up in Derry
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
800 miles away on the Malaysian side of
Borneo Wildlife Photographer say David
NT searches for the helmeted hornbill to
promote its value alive here in this
area in the lowland forest when I walk
to the to the forest and I hear them I
get excited you know once you're near
you you your feeling is different you
you want to get you want to capture the
sound and the behavior of the hornbill
it's it's a very exciting moment when
you when I see them my fears for the
helmet and hornbill since there are
poaching actively in Southeast Asia
particularly in Indonesia and I think
they are now in Malaysia so I'm worried
about our population here in Sabah
[Music]
the near extinction of the hornbill
depends on a network of smugglers one of
the biggest centers is potosi BAU where
a smuggler agreed to explain how the
trade operates if his identity was
obscured
calendula Ranko who CC ee from the
reaper drama to Columbia Lima program
katas dari a longshot oh poor Lavinia
Nam Utah in its Victor Garcia I under do
care Anika new da dee da ba Dei Gratia
to me unlikely ocarina yeah
Ida me Jamie in evil enough Skeeter
Naruto Emily man you talk to me
passe ici à la jolla Mooney opium Dadd
Onegin DC upon to the beginning target
impose an or imodium criminal morally on
a Margita begin the trade with China is
extensive especially for traditional
remedies for which no scientific
evidence exists this preserved Pangolin
is the most poached mammal in the world
[Music]
the deepest maybe stuff
these men are dire key man who live in
some guy who teak they are the
custodians of one of the helmeted
hornbills last remaining nesting areas
terrible car guitar
they patrol the forest to prevent
poachers coming onto their land but with
over 9,000 Hector's to protect the task
is far from easy
oh yeah that sounds like it a salary
cigar dolo Rock to Qatar the burble
probably don't attend to that antennas
to our Idol sir Kalani to certain Asuka
- amber Puna McAlary to literally noon
that is Kara sample blocking Valentina
meanwhile in the village Dyke people
celebrate their spiritual connection
with the hornbills when they consider
messengers of the spirits and symbols of
virility a pig is sacrificed to appease
the gods and spirits and to receive
blessings from them the pig's blood is
then offered to the gods as a sign of
respect
[Music]
after the ceremony the local leaders saw
the footage of the smuggler their deep
knowledge of the helmeted hornbills
behavior underscored why poaching was
the primary cause for this birds
extinction Buddhists were trying to look
for this helmet
finally at midday today we heard a call
again this is the fourth day we heard
the call and suddenly from nowhere you
know right across the river it just went
over our head
and perch on the big tree when they
finally threw across my head yeah yeah
and I was clicking away you know like
terror and it's the feeling of getting
the shot is fantastic because it's hard
work you know you're trying to look for
it for days we're trying to listen and
track in the forest so it's incredibly
amazing I'm very pleased and exhausted
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]